bah excellent yusufzai squeeze et jose
se trouve sur what's inside the box
aujourd'hui on va jouer un casse tête
chinois zen vous ai déjà joué un casse
tête chinois cost est petit c'est sur
vos parents vous ont offert en espérant
se débarrasser de vous pendant au moins
une heure c'est parti c'est 30 énigmes à
l'issue desquelles on verra ce qu'il ya
dans cette [ __ ] de boîte
ok premier casse-tête c'est des boutons
on a eu les quatre et on passe à la
suite deuxième énigme est encore un
bouton bah voila j'ai juste à déplacer
les formes appuyé sur le bouton non mais
on en est vraiment là là donc ça c'est
un conteur de boutons hoya défend et
bien falloir mettre de côté 2 3 4 5 1 2
3 1 2 3 4
alors la mêlée qu'il est doué mais qu'il
est doué mais dit on n'a pas de doute on
sait très bien que squeeze le génie
trouvera la solution mais pas la
modestie alors là vous faire un nom mais
les gars on est au cou à la une en cm2
on est en coin bordel de merde je
parlais trop vite en fait de lui peut
qu'aller en haut ou en bas ce qui est
très chiant ah ben voilà j'ai trouvé
c'est bon en fait c'est juste cliquer là
haut up du coup on a fait monter
celui-là est celui-là on peut le ramener
oui attend que ça veut dire ça peut-être
faut appuyer sur les deux en même temps
mode vitesse à temps et si vous avez une
idée comment on fait bordel pour moi
logement ça voudrait dire j'ai pu une
fois puis non puis oui là je sèche lasse
pas possible on est assis sur 30 et est
dure comme ça allait jouer un indice à
désolé désolé mais là c'est trop dur
utilise des flèches se trouvait de le
caresser une flèche de gauche et l'oeil
droit et la croix michel bronn flèche
gauche sont collés on va donc du coup je
pense offert claque gauche gauche droite
droite droite gauche gauche gauche
droite droite et au clic énorme fail
comme achement ça joue qu'à la souris du
coup ça ça veut dire gauche et sa droite
voilà c'est beau d'accord on à la
recherche des boutons savez voilà et
ensuite hop on n'en parle plus à tence
tunisie la bombe appuyé sur tous les
boutons
adacore bas ça c'est le chemin de qu'il
faut faire voilà tout simplement voilà
on en voit plus fallait faire un 2e ici
mon gars alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
ça il ya un truc le long du bouton ça
doit indiquer si c'est le premier ou par
exemple il ya un seul truc tu sais le
premier league en a de lui c'est le 2e
4e et 3e et on en parle plus abonnez
vous je suis super chaud la shon fire
alors ou là qu'il faut faire la bonne
question du système en anglais c'est ça
ou pas
satisfaction j'ai un horizon est un
génie moga al-ahmar contrôlent plus trop
qui s'il faut faire en fait quand
j'appuie une fois là c'est lui qui
s'allume quand j'appuie là c'est celui
d'avant quand j'appuie l'art deux fois
c'est lui qui s'allument c'est super dur
à expliquer donc le but c'est de faire
un deux trois quatre
hop un deux trois hommes un deux hommes
1 up et c'est fini et vous avez rien
compris et ça que j'ai rêvé de ce quiz
c'est qu'on comprend rien fûtreaux
résonner haut c'est dans une autre
langue c saf euros pour vous mais au fur
de la zone asie néonazis quoi est-ce
qu'on partirait pas sûr essayer toutes
les possibilités comme des bons gros
cons franchement elle citait malin tu le
passes en faisant ça je suis désolé
c'est pas s'ils ont franchement
combinaison à trois chiffres et tu fais
le tour des possibilités rapidement one
néo savez one [ __ ] et qu on y croit je
suis désolé le coup réseau là c'est quoi
081 et furent au cf 4 fort bah ouais je
me fais casse tête depuis que mes
parents veulent plus débarrasser de moi
donc c'est hier mon dernier du coup
alors là qu'il faut faire faut emboîter
les pièces elle dans l dans l est dans l
ok puis à voulez savoir la logique
désole t au-dessus du casse-tête quand
tu arrives à le résoudre sans que sa
fille casse la tête
où est ce que je me dis oh oh quel est
le phoque et la corrélation entre ces
boutons ça c'est fait alors cette fois
je peux me permettre
on sera pas baisé les gaza par exemple
ici je me suis là vous rendez bien
compte c'est gauche haut droite haut à
gauche à droite
à la c1 double [ __ ] c'est shawn
enlacés chômage non non ce sera chaud et
assez bon qu'avec lui la up
hop hop voilà hyper simple suis là
n'avait rien de compliqué ou là là on
part sur injonction de cd piratés le
digicode à l'immeuble 07 10 77 0 et le
coup c'est le zéro c'est quoi art est
vendable le zéro c'est quoi je comprends
pas la 1 2 je crois que j'ai compris
donc là c'est 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0c comme
ça sur un digicode 071 07 01 sec
voilà suivant on résout une énigme
d'enfants et on est heureux [ __ ] c'est
beau à thonon mais là non mais là
arrêter à un moment nous prendre pour
des hold up
hop hop voilà là là je veux dire il
fallait pas être news attention il est
dur il est redoutable celui-là il me
pose une colle wadani hamadi là vraiment
je sèche
one direction la direction du vent
pardon à north east west south hockey
fait pas semblant personne n'avait vu
venir
et ouais les gars ou la cus et que ça à
foot j'aime et usa une couleur ça
j'adore ça on adore mais saisit l'énigme
pour ce apparemment afin de simplifier
le bac dans 30 ans bac sera ça j'ai mon
bac clac clac vers le haut
lui en bas quand j'ai cliqué sur cela
sera la fin donc je vous explique avant
en gros tu suis le sens l'euro signifie
le point départ donc c'est celui-là tu
vas en bas à droite puis tu vas en haut
puis tu vas en bas à gauche suave et en
bas à gauche plus bas à droite voilà ce
que dit le prof pops hockey faire des
boîtes donc les embrouilles aller comme
ça là et là vous avez crois que j'ai
quitté mes joues je vous assure que non
et avant de l'accuser fléchi regardez
déjà si c'est la bonne réponse
ok j'ai triché c'est faux c'est faux
alors vraiment en forme
alors là comment on fait ier il
d'histoire de boutons plus de lait et je
comprends pas le rapport entre les
boutons et les pièces
voilà c'était de ok j'ai compris les
boutons représenter les côtés de la
pièce où il y avait un
c'est super chiant changer de vidéos
alors coeur v flèche coeur peut-être par
rapport au nombre de led pied dans
chaque mot c'est pas ça aide par rapport
aux nombres de côté c'est pas ça alors
là je sèche linge ok je vois la neige ou
indice parce que là ça me paraît un peu
débile mirrored numbers quatre nombres
inversée quel numéro face à un miroir
donne un coeur à sa c12 aux caisses et
les lignes céline qui ont bloqué ma
vision clac clac sa recette
oui le sais tu leur tourne et il
duplique ça par contre ça il n'est pas
homologué ce chiffre à 6 à 1
l fallait trouver un new scène c'est
quoi ça abba est ce que ce n'est pas
comme tout à l'heure east north south
east allez me dire aussi que ces énigmes
c'est génial à tambour noirot pas se
plaindre à envoyer ça c'est pareil comme
tailleur c'est le départ droite ou
gauche haut droite haut et c'est la fox
box faut faire une boiboite c'est une
boîte dans une boîte mexes et / ou pas
et combien olala même la caméra a été
impressionné par cette énigme
en gros fallait faire une boîte dans une
boîte les amis nous sommes maintenant
proches du but
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel à
voilà la solution voilà blanc noir là il
faut un blanc et la boutique s est bien
tombé 29
il va falloir tourner de la même couleur
c'est ça ça c'est l'énigme voilà bac
2020 c'est fait count up all what à
hockey par exemple au sénat et
combientième lettres dans l'alphabet le
haut j'ai dû me gourer à non ok orgueil
c'est plus complexe que ça il faut
effectivement trouvé la comédienne
l'aide ça représente dans l'alphabet et
ensuite il faut juste cliquer dans
l'ordre le eu est avant le f qui est
avant le m qui est avant le co qui est à
l'enjeu
est-ce qui est avant le thé mais c'est
sûr c'est ça recommence à faire là à mon
avis ça relève de l'anglais en fait
savoir c'est que j'arrive pas non en
termine sur un fait non ok je viens de
comprendre j'ai dû réfléchir dans ça
m'énervait ne pas comprendre et terminer
le jeu sur sa route hop au lit il faut
cliquer sur la première lettre du
chiffre de chaque niveau
one two swiss externe semaine jean jean
ok y'a quoi dans la boîte donc moi des
bonbons vous m'avez pris pour un [ __ ]
d'âne je m'en bats les couilles des
bonbons tu m'aurais mis un pikachu dans
la boîte à la place des bombes ou gt
rôle fait quoi mais je ne tiens pas
céder aux sur what's inside the box
n'étaient pas là mais ça vous a plu à
écouter c'était bien sûr monsieur ça
change et ça nous a fait réfléchir un
petit peu ça fait treize matière grise
il ya 13 prochaine vers ça vous regarde
et portez vous bien tu puisses